the jurogan experience
did you see the fight no no oh my god
dude he's one of the greatest
heavyweight fights of all time one of
the greatest boxing matches of all time
have you seen it yet jamie
i we can't hear you yes yes i watched it
live yeah yeah did you share your pants
uh no i was tired long day so i was just
sort of watching it did you scream out
at all no you don't scream out of things
still do you i i will on occasion but i
like have to be real riled up buckeye
stuff right uh it depends really i'll be
honest i'm trying to think the last time
i did
actually something happened i screamed
on occasion when kanye and kim got
divorced
when kim showed up with that crazy mask
on
no
dude that fight had us screaming we were
so it was an eye we had an awesome
watching party yeah because so it was uh
it was phil it was uh lara bytes and it
was uh tony and i jimmy batulo yeah
joe marsco all these friends of tony's
and tony's family and it was [ __ ]
amazing it was a it was a
you know there's something about
watching fights with a bunch of people
it's very festive you know when
everyone's screaming and cheering on
it's like it's more exciting it's like
you got a small crowd it's almost like
you're watching it live when you are
watching it live but you're almost like
watching in a small crowd yeah and it
was cool because like we'd go to a lot
of cities on a lot of different nights
there's never a boxing match like that
like we don't ever really do a viewing
party like that but it was so fitting
that we were
to me that we were an hour away from
youngstown which is like a real boxing
city yeah you know boom boom and kelly
pavlick and all those greats
uh that came out of there well it's just
be able to watch that fight live yeah
and catch it live because it was so good
it was so crazy it was so action-filled
i mean it was [ __ ] amazing from tyson
fury knocking wilder down early to
wilder looking like he was done with his
right hand boom
he had tyson fury on coheir street look
at how that punch look at how that
that's what they call it because you
don't know what's going on it's odd it's
a word for odd it's an old it's an old
saying it's nothing to do with gay folks
look at this boom look at this punch
look at the fat watch his fat ripple oh
wow look at that ripple crazy all the
way all the way down bro that's how hard
deontay wilder punches let me see that
again because that is there's maybe one
or two other humans that have ever lived
that could punch as hard as this guy
he's without a doubt one of the hardest
punches of all time so he smashes tyson
fiore while he's getting his ass kicked
smashes him with his right hand the
fourth round look at that fat rolled
down crazy look at that fat look at it
rolled down
i mean that's the shock waves that
ripple through his head most human
beings right there are going out most
human beings
and then he hits them again and clubs
them to the ground there hit him behind
the ear he he's a murderous puncher but
the the level of skill
was so evident the difference is tyson
fury is a masterful boxer i mean he's
masterful the [ __ ] that he did was
amazing and his strategy was amazing
just stay glued to deontay wear on them
hang on them make them work and just
just just drag them deeper and deeper
and deeper into these [ __ ] horrible
waters filled with crocodiles that's
what he did and almost got knocked out
doing it yeah that's how dangerous
wilder is
wilder is like
the opposite of usyk
like usyk is like this insane boxer
who's like this insane footwork in
motion and wilder kind of looks awkward
at times but if he hits you once you're
[ __ ] yep even if you're the one of the
greatest boxers of all time like tyson
fury if you're one of the great he's
without a doubt one of the greatest
heavyweight boxers ever six foot nine
277 pounds
and
lightning fast for a guy that big he
moves so well he moves his jabs
incredible i mean isn't it crazy destiny
what are the odds that that guy
who could be paul jenkins or mike smith
just as easily his name is tyson fury a
heavyweight
god his name tyson fury what are the
odds of that it's amazing like mike
tyson
one of the goats
fury
six nine yeah
crazy greatest name of all time yeah
that's like that's like a great comedian
literally his parents named him like
funny pants smith or something
joe king
yeah hey we know a joke well his whole
family was into fighting like he was
learning how to box from the time he was
a small small boy like he's always known
how to box
deontay wilder didn't even take up
boxing until he was 19. and deontay
wilder won a bronze medal in the olympic
games a year and a half after boxing wow
he's a special talent
just just insane power
but the difference in the level of
understanding of where to be and where
not to be how to move how to how to
faint and how to draw reactions and set
traps the differences
out of this world
but deante hit so hard it almost didn't
matter it almost didn't matter the tyson
fury was so much more skillful and so
much slicker with so much more
experience tyson fury hits so [ __ ]
hard that it almost didn't matter
my dad's girlfriend had her
head in her hands after that
round where fieri got knocked down twice
it was great because she just like was
she felt bad for this guy that was
getting beat up on and i touched her
shoulder and i go that guy's gonna come
back and win this fight and she goes
really
you might have been wrong i could have
easily have been wrong but you're
talking [ __ ] now i know what the hell's
going on he didn't know jack [ __ ] no one
knew jack [ __ ] in that fight when he got
dropped we all thought it was over i was
like oh my god he's [ __ ] because he
got hit hard you could tell like when he
got up he was not really there and then
he got clubbed in the back of the head
and fell down again or about behind the
ear and fell down again i was like oh my
god but then he came back
he did come back the craziest comeback
ever was him in the 12th round of the
first fight that was the craziest
that's nuts that didn't even make sense
but there was some controversy about
this fight
and one of the controversies was the
extremely long counts
when tyson fury went down cormier
believes purely benefited from crazy
slow count that's right after being
knocked down by wilder daniel cormier
believes the referee made a bad call in
the fourth round versus uh fury versus
wilder three well he's correct this is
what happened the count is supposed to
the referee is supposed to go one two
when the guy goes down but if for any
reason
he has to interrupt the count because
like they're like another the fighter
the the other the opponent needs to be
told to go to the neutral corner you're
supposed to pick up the count where the
ringside counter has it so there's a guy
who's counting ringside and he'll keep
the count going so if you're at one
two and then you're like go to a neutral
corner that guy's supposed to be like
three
four
five i should but he didn't oh he went
back to it three
four but the guy had already been down
for a couple seconds without a doubt it
was a long count that's [ __ ] that's
the problem with boxing though that's
what people have a problem with that's
like considered kind of like [ __ ]
it's one of two things it's either a
mistake and the guy made an error
or maybe there's a i don't think i don't
think those there's a different law
in new in vegas i don't think the law i
don't think there's a rule that allows
them to do that i think it's an error
or corruption
right most likely an error most likely
the guy's panicking he's in this huge
fight i don't know how many big
high-profile fights i'm not that well
schooled on uh boxing referees i know a
few of them i used to know more of them
back in the day but i know a few of them
i didn't i haven't i don't know if i've
seen that guy work before so i don't
know if he's panicking
but boxing's got a lot of there should
be somebody overseeing him though that
goes hey you can't do that exactly there
should be a thing that's like loud as a
guy goes down here's my take on it it
shouldn't be up to the referee to count
it shouldn't be he can go one two three
or you can go one
two it shouldn't be that this should be
a count right it should be ten seconds
and there should be like a lcd screen
yeah and when a guy goes down it starts
at ten and when he you know when it gets
to or starts at one or zero whatever i
feel like japanese or chinese they do
that right
something like that i feel like i've
seen that before
in what in boxing i think
i feel like it's a different thing it's
like a loud over the one but it's like
chinese words or whatever well i know
they've done that on some boxing
telecasts where you hear the ringside
count i know that for a fact and i know
guys have picked it up at certain picked
it up at five six
but in this case
there was without a doubt like a gap
where he was
directing some stuff inside the ring and
then he came back and picked up the
count so it was definitely long
the question is could fury have gotten
up
maybe but could he have gotten up two
seconds earlier three seconds earlier
whatever the extra count was and could
wilder have jumped on him and heard him
again yeah that's possible too
you don't know when a guy gets that hurt
if you give them any extra time is a
bonus any three seconds four seconds
that makes a big difference that's
between the world spinning and also the
world's not spinning anymore well i
noticed that ref kept doing that put
your gloves up now walk towards me with
your gloves up and then he would wipe
the gloves like he did it each free at
least he kept it sort of consistent but
that's standard yeah that's standard
because you got to find out if a guy if
a guy goes down and then you go put your
gloves that walk towards me and he walks
towards you and he's like start
stumbling stop the fight right because
you don't know it's just it's just
guesswork and it's all subjective right
one referee will stop a fight when a guy
is getting [ __ ] up and another referee
will let it go
there's a lot of referees who had to
stop this fight earlier there's quite a
few referees where when tyson fury was
battering
deontay wilder they would have stopped
the fight you know and this was uh
wilder's
argument about the first fight or the
second fight when he did get stopped he
felt like he could have kept going
judging by this fight he probably is
correct he probably could have kept
going
but he might have gotten knocked out
there but he could have kept going like
in this fight it looked like in that one
round i think it was the second where
tyson fury dropped deontay wilder and he
barely survived and he made it to the to
the end bell what if that was the
beginning of the round you know what if
what if you know who knows it's it's you
never know so could he have gone on from
the second fight when they stopped the
fight probably
you know maybe it was like for his
health that his uh corner through the
towel and stopped the fight maybe they
know him and they know how tough he is
that's what you see in this fight you
see how [ __ ] tough he is how much
pain and how much punishment he endured
and still was dangerous still hurt fury
and still hurt him again after that
right he hurt him one other time later
didn't drop him but hurt him so he hurt
him on a few occasions
but when he went out man he went out bad
he went out but that's a bad knockout
yeah that was a bat and tyson fury said
it best he goes that's the kind of
knockout that can end a career
yeah i mean it might not but that was a
bad knockout
show the knockout he wings a left hook
misses it and steps in with a right hand
that just spins his head around
it was crazy yeah hitting the mat like
woke him up he was out on his way down
yeah and when we were watching we were
like this is the greatest fight i've
ever seen in my life yeah so fun
the thing is it's like
does he comes back from that like
he's 35 i think his trainer said he
doesn't want him to even think about it
he just wants him to do nothing but rest
don't even think about boxing just take
a rest you earned it like let's just
don't don't get all anxious and ramp up
for the rematch because that's what he
did for this this fight apparently
when he got beaten in the second fight
and he felt like there was all sorts of
controversy attached to it and
it got real ugly with the accusations
like he accused all but accused his
trainer of being involved in it it was
his trainer who was mark breeland let's
watch this again look at this watch the
end the left here's the right boom okay
i mean
bro
out that is crazy
that is a crazy knockout
and in a fight look at one more time see
it again he hits him with the right hand
he knows he's got him hurt lets him go
left hand here's the left misses with
the well boom he clipped him with the
left too but the right was perfect
[ __ ]
what a fight
and when it was over we were like holy
[ __ ] what a rollercoaster ride yeah
well one of the most exciting boxing
matches of all time for sure hell yeah
crazy that a guy's six nine going up
against a guy six six like six seven
true heavyweight yeah crazy true
heavyweight fight the other thing was
deante wilder was 238 for that fight
which is the heaviest of his career he
was 209 for their first fight
yeah
and it's like
you know is that good was it good to put
all that extra weight on like maybe
maybe it helped him fight him off maybe
it hindered his movement if you could
teach deontay wilder footwork like real
footlord how to bounce and move and
slide in slide out and not be awkward at
all to be slick
god with that punch
it's almost like the punches it's almost
like it hinders a fighter in a certain
way have that kind of power because you
know all you have to do is hit a guy so
all you're thinking about doing is
hitting him and it worked 49 41 times
like he's knocked out 41 guys or 40. i
think he's like
41 yeah he had one decision
out of his 41 victories which is crazy
that's the craziest record in the
history of the sport there's not a
single guy that's knocked out as many
guys
as deontay wilder has if you could teach
that guy how to move like tyson fury
does if you could teach that guy how to
pretend he doesn't have any power like
just really develop real boxing skills
just move and just almost pretend you
can't break an egg
just be in the right position always and
just touch people just touch because he
hits so [ __ ] hard man but people that
have that kind of power
for whatever reason they always
not always but a lot of times they rely
on it because it's so extraordinary they
just know that all they have to do is
land that one shot the guys who are like
the masterful boxers they never have
that like the julio cesar chavez's of
the world he's one of the most masterful
boxers ever but he never was like a one
punch guy he would break guys down he
would very rarely stop someone with one
punch in the first round most of the
fights it was just him just beating the
[ __ ] out of people like super
technically and he would just move in
and throw shots and every shot was
coming your way was accurate and
eventually he'd break fighters down and
smash them
but if you can get a guy like deontay
wilder to pretend he doesn't have power
and to learn how to box like a julio
cesar chavez he's definitely one of the
greatest fighters of all time
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify